hi again this is the second
stage of talk about enlightenment
Enlightenment to me
I was talking to some people on our
monthly Zoom
and I started telling them about uh
my one of my alignments and try to tell
the experience
it's almost like but it's like me
telling you a story
you could be engrossed in the story
or you can be confused in the story
I don't know what he's talking about I I
don't know
what what he felt
I can hear the words but I've no idea
what he's talking about
so I'm going to try and put this in her
perspective
with Aikido and the techniques
let's say you're going to do a from
solid basic sheeranagi
katatadori that means um they're white
and
grips your left wrist fragment looks
like
they hold really strong
instantly you might think oh this is
going to be difficult I can really feel
their strength
and you feel then grounded
it bothers you
when you're a beginner
you struggle with another person of your
own level perhaps
and that doesn't bother you because
you're trying to do it they're trying to
do you're both struggling
as the years go by
you will get better
and you'll find that the beginners can
not do exactly what
you want them to do with their body
and they mess up your shinagi because
they move they move wrongly you know
they don't they don't move how it's
programmed as planned
so you start telling them how they got a
hole and how they got to stand how
they've got to blend
so they're not really the best people to
train with
this is what your mind is thinking
so so you can either train with someone
of your own level your own grade
and that's always enjoyable
because you may have really good
training together you may be really
finely balanced but really this is on a
technical level
if you go into the black belts once you
get to the black belts and you can then
do it on everybody normally below you
you might get the odd person who makes
you struggle and normally you're about
to do it on most people
so you're sharing Aggies are getting
better you can do it on most people
below you if you get somebody hiring
than you let's say you're second down
and you've got a third down holding you
same sharing Aggie
and they've given you about a hard time
and you're thinking what am I going to
do to
get through this person you know you
want to be a third Dan as far as you
want to move them but you realize that
their their knowledge and their time in
their heart has got more depth than you
and it's it's like starting all over
again
so you can
for a little bit of confidence go back
and train with the lower grades know
that you can do this here and I guess
yes you're quite happy but um The
Challenge in your mind this thinking in
your mind
about going back to try on the higher
grades
because it's bothering you
he already defeated
so
my message really here is
if you and it was an enlightened being
you wouldn't have doubt
you wouldn't have ego
you wouldn't have
desire to want to achieve
you would just have the the now the
present
and when they squeeze your wrist
it wouldn't bother you because it would
be and like an all-encompassing Joy
if you remember back to the film where I
was saying about the warm cloud
not like a breeze of warmth but a warmth
around you
that you are part of
and you don't feel solid anymore
you actually feel like you are part of
that warm air
and and however far that warm air
expanded
you would be part of it
you don't even go to think how far can I
expand in this warm air because if you
do that you're coming back to being what
I call a human being again
is what I call Natural thinking if
you're in the inline stage
you just glow and you would be in a
place of bliss
and like with the points I was talking
about of religion
and how it doesn't matter what religion
I was actually going to
this glow of warmth this presence
what is
I say not this world but it must be this
world why someone's about to feel it but
it's just an expression people say
but it's a warmth that when we say not
of this world we don't feel it easily we
don't find it every day
most people will never find it I'm very
very grateful so so grateful that I
that it chose to find me really
I just happened to go along
with another with other people who
wanted me to
be immersed within their religion and to
find the glory and the beauty they find
but I didn't go to pray I just went to
listen
and I found that I was immersed within
this wonderful
glow energy warmth our robotic
experience whatever you may wish to put
the name tag on it
so you become part of this so when they
grip
it's like a joy it's like this warmth
coming into you
you don't feel think of as a person you
just think that they become another part
of this this warmth this glow
this
deep love really
you don't look at them all their male
they're female you just absorb
and you absorb this this wonderful
feeling
The Human Side tells you that it's Shia
Naggy that you're going to perform
so you carry out the shianagi
you both
glide through it because the warmth of
the air
you don't check the distance you don't
need to check the distance that you're
going to travel within this Movement we
call sharonagi
it's just pure joy
if you understand this and you get it
correct
not only do you in
get this joy for your partner receives
it as well
they may not be attuned as you are while
this is happening but they will find
that your Technique was very smooth
very
are so beautiful because
if it doesn't give harm
then it must have Beauty to it
if it doesn't have wand
it has Beauty
it so the expression of shiyanagi is
like a calligraphy brush just being
scrolled beautifully across
the parchment paper
and only when the hand comes off
well the
calligraphy be complete
to me that's shiranagi
performed under an Enlightenment stage
that you can go through
I'll talk more about this in uh
the next film that I'll make on the
subject
it's like an ounce of Body Experience
I was fortunate enough to have it happen
in small flashes when it first started
and but one of the times I remember very
vividly was I was teaching a seminar
and my dojo in
a village called Orwell I had the dojo
at the bottom of my garden and I was
teaching
um a seminar
and I I had this experience and I'd had
it for around about two months it was as
if whatever I performed whatever I
done within
the dojo
I had this feeling of almost
yes I can see my feet moving I'd see my
hands moving I knew I was moving but it
was as if
there was no effort everything had a
correct path that it should flow on
a sheer Maggie would have its correct
path I cut the geese would have its
correct path for women Aggie so
everything would have a quick path there
would be no physical Clash with with the
people that I done it on
because it was as if this
Out of Body Experience
was Within Me
all the time
while on the mat
it must have been with me in daytime as
well when I was going to work uh bring
up my family
he must be with me but I didn't notice
that
but I did notice it on the on the tatami
it's very strange because
I used to question it was if I would
step out and look at myself and say
why does it feel so good why is there
nothing that seems to be difficult
whatever you're performing at the moment
I believe I was about a third damn
I can't remember second or third Dan
anyhow
that's besides the point but it was it
was um with me for nearly two months and
this on this seminar
I was so the showman was in front of me
but I was teaching uh
a couple of uh people who were
struggling so after demonstrating
I went over
to the
right hand side of the dojo and I still
see the window now in my mind and I
remember standing there explaining to
the couple about the technique
and in my lower half of my right leg
um
about where the shin is
I started to
feel as if somebody had removed very
small plaque
if you can imagine a an old-fashioned
sink plug that you put in on the chain
but a very very small one about the size
of my finger
and it was as if I found this hole
and I fell
all my
warmth and my outboard experience
draining out through this hole in my leg
it was such a weird sensation
because I could feel that Tony the human
being was coming back
to himself and the out of body
experience was being drained away
it bothered me so much I said to the
seniors carry on I'm just going to go to
the house
I walked up to the house
because I needed to work out why this
had happened why why had I done to make
this happen why am I after two months of
holding this outbod experience where all
techniques were smooth and flowing
not giving me any difficulty who have I
done it on
why was it now
leaving me
I never got the answer then
I never I haven't got the answer to tell
you today
in the next film I will go into
things a little bit deeper
thank you for listening and I hope
you're finding it of some interest thank
you